it is a battle between the government
and the gangs I tell you every day this
year more than five people have been
killed
it's bonkers I'd never been to Rio
before it's famous through time because
of this sort of almost as as glamorous
feel about it looks absolutely amazing
Rio is a really cool place you know it's
everything that you imagine it's gonna
be it's beautiful you have that iconic
curved Beach
[Music]
the people are very warm very friendly
there's just a real relaxed very chilled
out kind of kind of vibe
especially along and on the beaches all
you need to do is sort of look up and
around you and you see some of the more
famous landmarks that Rios known for its
football its people on the beaches and
then partying evening it's an amazing
atmosphere there and really sensation to
look at really quite amazingly beautiful
and at the same time like bang up
against all these beautiful apartments
and hotels literally next door and these
huge favelas which are extreme poverty
extremely violent and dangerous places
if you wander into them
even as you're driving in from the
airport you're passing favelas you
cannot miss the poverty as soon as you
arrive it is absolutely everywhere so
you have this huge glamour but also it's
surrounded by people who are living in
abject poverty
[Music]
and huge numbers of them right now there
are over a thousand favelas in Rio de
Janeiro from a distance the favelas look
quite beautiful they're climbing up the
hillside and visually they're really
quite something to look at when you
approach them though it becomes very
clear that you're entering a very very
different world indeed it's barricades
down every Street yeah why they don't so
the police cars can't get inside there
they're favela it's not like you can
just arrived at a favela and go inside
can't just openly filming
[Music]
got a contact they are closed areas
really nobody from the outside is
welcome unless you have somebody with
you who's from there
so you can't just wander in to a favela
what's happening in which what you do
okay we had an excellent guide with us a
young man who runs a project for kids in
the favela and he showed us around
because when with a guide it's fine
everyone knows him if we haven't cleared
it we wouldn't have got two steps I
showed us little spots where you could
see graffiti on the walls and art and so
you got a sense of identity within that
ravenna
you're walking through very narrow
alleyways and life is going on all
around you as you're doing this life is
just rustling it's loud it's noisy but
there is a very dark undertone to the
informal organization of the favelas
it's a completely unique environment
another dimensional motion
[Music]
right at the moment wrote some of the
most expensive apartment blocks in Rio
and yet across the highway the start of
the most violent favela they deal an
awful lot of cocaine out of that favela
and that cocaine is bought by the people
living in the rich apartments across the
road the fighting between the gangs and
the police there is almost continuous
these are massive firefights
a shooting incident in Rio is full-on
warfare for sometimes days at a time
you wouldn't imagine that in a city like
Rio de Janeiro that you would see scenes
which are basically like a frontline
warzone equivalent to anything I've ever
been involved in equivalent to anything
I've ever witnessed in any of the
hostile environments we've worked on
around the world it is much nearer to
being in a war zone than it is to being
in a what you would expect a gangland
fight with the police once you were in
those neighborhoods you could very well
have been in the alleyways of Mosul or
Raqqa we're talking a little skirmish
we're talking seven or eight hours of
proper and fighting with heavy weapons
and this is happening around
neighborhoods where people are getting
on with their daily life but the police
claim they're using the force to defend
themselves the problem being of course
is that those bullets are going
somewhere every day this year more than
five people have been killed in Rio
State by the police
most of those killings happen here in
the favelas that's five or six people
per day killed by the police
innocent people are getting caught up in
the crossfire you get the impression
that within those favelas life is cheap
and it's happening a few hundred meters
from a beach where rich people are
enjoying their holiday to highlight that
we thought footage of a police
helicopter circling a favela and this is
where you know families live in very
very dense proximity to each other and
this police helicopter was pouring
automatic fire down onto the favela it's
bonkers Rio is huge and as you might
expect traffic can be absolutely
terrible everyone uses driving apps but
there's a difference here they use one
that tells you where there's fighting
taking place shootings between the
police and the gangs in Portuguese it's
OTT but it's it translates as where's
the shooting sat-nav here tells you
where not to go so you'll get caught up
in a nasty it not how to get somewhere
quickly but how to get there alive
I mean it's best difficult to get your
head round but this is a red brick you
know it had various colors showing you
know various parts that were active and
there will be at least one to maybe half
a dozen maybe a dozen shootings at that
point in time he was a little bit
surprised that we hadn't even heard of
it before because surely you don't drive
around a city without having things to
tell you where the latest shooting is
taking place
it is a battle between the government
and the gangs with the police as a sort
of proxy in the middle to carry out the
government's about
we've been trying to make contact with
the drug factions can we go in no we've
done gangs in all sorts of different
countries you need to find somebody who
has links to them and we did find a guy
and he had to go into a period of
negotiation with the game that he knew
well you have to do a lot of
conferencing that it is in their
interest to talk to you to tell you
about why it is that they're doing what
they're doing it was about trust they
had to see us they had to actually have
a sense of who we were it was only a
meet and greet you can watch what we do
but you can't film it absolutely no
cameras don't even think about it if
we've done anything to take pictures
where they said we couldn't it was made
absolutely clear they were just killing
us on the spot they kill for Outsiders
on a regular basis who have come into
the favela who shouldn't have
they only wanted to meet at night
because it's safest for them and so we
we pulled up into this first area and it
was actually an item er of one of their
birthday parties they were absolutely
high on drugs and alcohol and it was
pretty scary cuz everyone's got a
machine gun this is serious these guys
aren't messing around the next day there
was a police raid one member of the gang
was killed we only found this out while
going to meet them for a second time and
I became very concerned at that moment
we're all a little concerned that these
guys might put two and two together and
come up with five and think that we
might have had something to do with it
what happens if they say Vega arrived
and then we had a raid hit us we sat
down and we had long to chat a talk
about it at a sort of cafe we wanted to
make sure that they weren't in any way
blaming us for the situation
if we didn't go back in then they really
would start thinking I have to say I
still have my doubts oh I wasn't 100%
sure on that
whole different atmosphere when we got
back the second time we were actually
looking at a proper business proper gang
we spent hours with him we could not
film a frame honestly I could have shot
a movie there it was incredible
everywhere you looked the whole time I
was standing there having my diplomatic
beer with these guys and I was just
thinking please let me shoot this please
let me shoot it was just incredible but
the consequences of doing something like
that could end up in your death it was
it was crazy one car pulled up and they
opened the back door and I'm stacked on
the back of it was cocaine which took up
basically the whole backseat was about
this high piles of it I've never seen
anything like it
after a couple of days of building a bit
of relationship the drug gang agreed to
speak to us on camera this is the first
time we've been allowed some freely
outside in the favela there's been a
police raid here over the last few days
and there's another one going on right
now so it's it's pretty dangerous area
always nervous you're nervous that the
police could come in and there's a huge
firefight you're nervous of then they
might suddenly change on you there's no
way to write me you have no idea where
you are and you couldn't get out just
couldn't get out we were told to go and
wake down an alleyway
we didn't know what to expect they're
coming this way an old master and now
old up I mean really tooled up I tell
you they were in serious business mode
when they came to meet us to talk on
camera there was no messing around they
look menacing and it's all the more
menacing because you know these guys are
the real deal
I mean getting into gun fights with the
police killing people it's something
they do on a daily basis how many are in
the group whether I say Amish it's
really very serious business right a big
business scene they need to make money
what is your main business within
okay you know they join a gang because
it's a legitimate business
you wrote a guy whose balaclava up
carrying a machine gun who clearly would
kill with impunity and yet he's making a
point that actually it's just business
it just happens to be a business that we
find in in normal society unacceptable
where in their society it's completely
acceptable these guys were properly
tooled up not just some old ak-47 really
sophisticated machine gun the quality of
their weaponry I mean it was up there it
would have been some of the world's
Special Forces would have been happy to
have some of this kit there's no denying
that these guys were a step up from your
your average gangster there were much
nearer to being a militia than it was to
being with a crime gang whatever we
perceive the crime gang to be they saw
it almost as if they were soldiers if
the police come in and try and affect
their business or try and disrupt their
way of life within the favela they
believe they have every right to defend
themselves
they're the business they're the main
guys and-and-and that came across in
spades we realized actually here that
the money man's the guy the accountant
who runs the books for the drug deals so
we get into the back of the car not
quite sure what to expect I got and then
have the most frank candid conversation
with this guy it's your job made worse
by the police
perfectly open about how he conducts
business the amount of money they bring
in the scale of the operation he was
bragging about anything he was just
telling us what he does for a living and
how it works and so you're in his car in
the favela we can hear firing taking
place because there's a ray just taking
place up the road but they're totally
relaxed
and then they pulled out this massive
wad of money and that was like two days
takings he was meticulous the notes were
wrapped in elastic bands they had very
detailed notes on collection date
collection times how much money he was a
proper accountant you expect them all to
be sort of bloodthirsty killers but
actually they're not it's just actually
a business and as he said all the
societies involved they were perfectly
happy to talk we were in their house
yeah and they and know that they're the
government's we wanted to visit a school
that was caught in the crossfire between
two rival drug gangs and also with
police operations
[Music]
it's right in the boundary between two
crime gangs and it's also on the main
route that the police take to come in
and attack the day was the first day
that the school has been open for the
last three days because of fighting here
we can't film anywhere but in this
little alleyway at the end of that we've
already passed gunman there's more that
way and there are more that way
this school is an oasis in the middle of
a war zone we were in there and we were
interviewing the headmistress is an
absolute firecracker she just gets out
her phone that's just the audio from
from here he starts playing me the sound
that they had recorded on our phone okay
so that's what I wrote that's the war
yes 15:30 record but to go over all days
the teachers also also took pictures of
their kids lying on the ground
scared while the firing was going on
just outside the window
with their hands over their ears who
just can't cope with that level of
violence and they're just little kids we
knew that this wasn't a one-off when we
saw on the roof of the school mr. sighn
on the television spaces the school
don't shoot and that's for the police
helicopters when they're doing the
operations I mean incredible you can't
imagine what that must be like for a 5 6
7 8 9 14 50 it would be terrifying for
me never mind a child who is in school
amongst all of this adventure that we
were having there is also the tragedy
that was very clear to us when we met
andria a lovely woman who had tragically
lost her husband he was actually a
brazilian jujitsu instructor who helped
local kids get off the street and give
them some structure in their lives he
was at this favela as they volunteered
to help kids find a different path
outside of violence she had arranged to
do the interview with us at the club
where her husband had taught jiu-jitsu
to the kids it was the first time she'd
been back to the gym since her husband
had been killed she walked in and the
reaction from the kids in the other
instructors was really really
heart-rending it
English special the kids out and then
greeted her and was very very emotional
for her my son does exactly the same
sport and I could see my boy in in the
same environment and then he suddenly
realized where you are and how dangerous
it all is I felt really choked up at the
time they volunteer to working with us a
raid took place it was sort of hiding
from the bullets and the police came
over and shot and he was killed outright
he was on his way to class
we often don't realize that in Brazil
does a terrible racist issue and that
her husband was killed because he fit
the criteria of somebody who would
possibly be a gang member
she wasn't full of hate or anything like
that she was still a kind compassionate
woman and then at the end of the
interview she pulls up a shirt shows
where she's been shot almost casually
you know oh yeah I I've been shot as
well hard line policies are really
mostly supported by people who are not
affected by them behind the current push
against the favela gangs as brazil's
newly elected president the government's
saying that they're going to eradicate
crime in the favelas job Olsen ro the
president he's just hardcore right-wing
the problem is is that a huge sections
of the country don't like this we had
only been in Brazil a day or two and
there was a huge demonstration on the
streets
and we first turned up I would say well
this is just like a party
we felt we were sort of more part of
just say a carnival Brazil so I mean
everything's an exclusive party isn't it
there's still you know great music there
was still a lot food going around the
place there was still a lot of dancing
[Music]
marceia our Brazilian producer said guys
you're being lured into a whole sense of
security
it will turn nasty an extreme far-left
element where they're definitely
intending to provoke a reaction from the
police
Richie's tried to get the best pictures
and trying to get right amongst it and
then we're trying to keep up with him
and there's always an element of chaos I
see these guys and I think I'll go and
get a shot of them they start to put
hands in front of the cameras and then
try and head a little bit
so I backed off because I did not want
to be the cause of a situation happening
suddenly the more anarchist side of the
protest group launched fireworks
directly over the police not just your
average firework Lipset it's the sort of
incendiary device decided to move
forward it was going to happen this last
bombs going off left right center just
trying to figure out
teamworks really important in a
situation like this because I'm
obviously concentrated on the pictures
and it's very easy to get tunnel vision
and not see what's happening around you
everybody's we're having to watch
everybody's back because the threat can
come from anywhere and it's people like
Dominique and Marcia who actually keep
her safe in those situations
it's already a war zone
it's difficult to see how it could get
any worse it's very easy to see these
gangs as extreme criminals which is
something that they are there's no
denying that
[Music]
these are people who are the
marginalized of society
there may be a policy to try and
eradicate the gangs but it's very
difficult to see how that can be done
when they are absolutely part of society
and poverty is everywhere so they are
there and probably there to stay
[Music]
you
[Music]